[Music]
foreign
have you ever wondered how to make a
website with 3D scroll animations
without using any code today we'll do
just that using figma Andorra before we
dive in make sure to download our free
UI ux Playbook with practical design
tips and tricks
alright let's get started we already
have a website design in figma if you
want to follow along you can find the
free source file in the description
below this video to get started select
the frame and open the figma to Dora
plugin now copy the layers to your
clipboard and head over to dora.run
Dora is awesome for Designing and
Publishing 3D and animated sites all
without a code if you don't have an
account yet go ahead and register for
free now
let's create a new project when you do
you'll notice a desktop size frame is
automatically created let's change that
to a Macbook 16 inch before we go any
further it's important to match our
frame height in Dora to the one we have
in figma for us it's
5772 pixels
now we're going to paste our layers into
this new frame
this part might take a few seconds or
even a couple of minutes a quick tip
try unselecting the frame while it's
processing
I found that this often speeds things up
a bit once your design is in Dora you
might notice that some elements look a
bit off
feel free to adjust their position
delete them or even recreate them
directly in Dora
now let's enhance our design by
incorporating 3D models
head over to sketchfab.com a great
resource for both free and paid 3D
models I'm going to search for ocean
animals and set filters to show only
downloadable and animated models that
are free but feel free to look for any
specific animal you like
once you've found a model you like go
ahead and download it in glb format
now that we've got our 3D model it's
time to bring it into Dora find the 3D
icon in the top bar and click and drag
to create a 3D widget
once that's set up import the 3D model
you just downloaded every 3D widget in
Dora contains a built-in default camera
to zoom in or out just use your mouse
wheel if you want to rotate the model
left click and drag and if you want to
move it around simply right click and
drag if you prefer you can also adjust
the values in the right sidebar to see
the animation
select the layer right below the 3D
scene and toggle it on
next let's make sure our design looks
good on different screen sizes to do
that adjust the 3D widget frame width to
100 viewport width
now for the main attraction on this page
I'll be using a 3D model of a sea turtle
there are some free options out there
but for this tutorial I'm using a paid
one I'll include links to the 3D models
in the description along with some free
Alternatives once you've picked your 3D
model download it and bring it into Dora
just like before set the width to 100
viewport width and connect the 3D widget
with the viewport top
[Music]
now when you open the keyframe panel and
move the viewport your sea turtle should
move along with it
fantastic we're now ready to bring the
sea turtle to life
so first things first let's select the
default camera
add your first keyframe when the handle
is at zero now
Slide the handle over to 32 and add a
second keyframe here's where we get a
little precise adjust the values in the
right sidebar according to the settings
I'm using
this way you can get the same animation
I've got down to the Last Detail
next move your handle to 88 and add
another keyframe and tweak the values
again
[Music]
at 120 add your next keyframe and fine
tune the values these incremental
changes are what's going to make your
animation smooth and eye-catching
alright move the handle to 170 and yes
you guessed it
another keyframe and another round of
adjustments it might seem like a lot of
steps but the final effect will be worth
it
let's keep going move the handle to 235
add a keyframe and adjust the values
almost there
slide to 280 and adjust the values
lastly move the handle to 310 and adjust
the values one more time
[Music]
that's it
let's check out how all this effort pays
off
thank you
the animated sea turtle really brings
the design to life
this kind of dynamic element is not just
eye-catching it's also on Trend in the
design World offering an immersive
experience to your users
before we wrap up there's one more
crucial tip
to make your entire website responsive
don't forget to add constraints to your
elements directly in Dora this ensures
that your design adjusts beautifully on
different screen sizes
it's worth mentioning that Dora is still
evolving
while it's pretty awesome already you
might run into some limitations
especially when it comes to
responsiveness
but the good news is that the platform
is getting better all the time so keep
an eye out for updates as it's likely to
offer an even better experience in the
near future
to get your website live just hit
publish and that's it
you've transformed your static figma
design into a vibrant animated 3D
website
see you in the next video